elle arrive protéger dans des
sarcophages les oeuvres sont des balles
et une à une et on découvre un monde
imaginaire avec des hommes à tête
d'oiseau pro visage difforme
ou alors au corps vidé de leurs
entrailles que les morceaux se met en
place
n'est ce géant
cet univers c'est celui du sculpteur
david altmejd pour sa première
rétrospective il crée sur place au musée
quelques oeuvres originales et en les
ignorant sans baisse parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est vraiment quand
mes mains gauches la matière que je met
de la vie dans l'objet ce qu'on prend
c'est comme ça ce moment là que les
choses commencent à vivre et respirer
est vraiment fort a existé un ca que
c'est avec le c'est à partir du moment
où je suis en contact avec elle qu'elle
est vraiment les choses comme ça david
hâle mais de 40 ans est née et a grandi
à montréal
il a obtenu un baccalauréat à l'uqam et
a poursuivi ses études à l'université
columbia à new york où il vit depuis 16
ans
regardez cet immense boîte de plexiglas
c'est une oeuvre en soi fait d'un
condensé de la production de l'artiste
au cours des 15 dernières années je me
suis vraiment concentré sur la
fabrication du mouvement ont par exemple
on voit un loup garou ici on peut voir
que son bras est en train d et
fragmentée et démultipliée ça c'est
comme pour créer un effet de d'animation
donc si on suit le breuil du loup garou
un comme ça qui tourne un peu autour de
la sculpture
on se rend compte qu il est en train
d'essayer d'un chat c'est d'attraper un
raisin alors certes un petit moment du
monde c'est mieux
louga vous pourquoi un loup garou
quand l'homme se transforma le gard où
il passe d'un état à un autre complément
et j'adore cette dualité
cette tension je veux toujours que mon
travail soit plein de tension le plus
possible parce que ça lui donne une
énergie ce qui est totalement lui par
contre ce sont ses mains il les a
reproduits de nombre de fois et on les
retrouve sur quantité d'oeuvres la main
pour moi ça symbolise le travail
l'objet qui est en train de se faire
l'énergie qui relié à la fabrication à
la construction et de construire david
almeida n'arrête jamais
son rayonnement international s'accroît
une rétrospective similaire à celle de
montréal a été présentée l'hiver dernier
à paris et au luxembourg
ces oeuvres font aujourd'hui partie des
collections de grands musées et
collectionneurs privés
il aurait pu choisir toutes autres
formes d'art david altmejd a choisi la
sculpture ce que je trouve
extraordinaire en sculpture c'est là que
c'est le fait que la sculpture existe
dans l'espace réel ans contrairement à
la photo au cinéma à la peinture qui
existent us dans un espace de
représentation un espace à autre la
sculpture elle existe dans le même
espace que le corps du spectateur ce
spectateur qui parfois se sent intimidé
devant l'art contemporain on ne sait
trop comment apprécier ou comprendre
certaines oeuvres
ce que j'espère c'est que les gens vont
pouvoir approcher le travail sans à sur
la défensive qui vont se laisser être
fasciné par les détails du travail ils
peuvent aimer ils peuvent détester
ils peuvent voir ce qu'ils veulent ils
peuvent trouver ce suspect ils peuvent
adoré ça peut les inspirer mais comme
ils ont aucune obligation ils peuvent
faire ce qu'ils veulent
david altmejd nous invite à poser un
regard nouveau sur l'art contemporain
moi j'aimerais bien voir si un enfant va
avoir un problème à être fasciné par des
scripteurs comme ça mais jamais
exactement
alors preuve qu'il faudrait peut-être
apprendre des enfants à prendre des
enfants venaient en art contemporain et
amplis un autre chose ça fait un peu
sauf de sarcelles